so one last story and this is something
I've went into great detail on my show
because I think it's really important
for us to understand what neoliberalism
is and you may feel like this is coming
out of the blue but it's very it has
been a linear progression leading up to
this for me and my audience and and my
followers on Twitter because I was
accused of being a neoliberal and the
other day and I for the you know for the
radio audience I'm I did air quotes I
was accused of being a neoliberal and
once they accused me of being a
neoliberal I realized that you know
people probably just don't understand
what neoliberalism really is and if but
then not only do they not understand
what neoliberalism really is and maybe
they do and they just have reduced it
down to nothing more than a pejorative
but what really matters is if you're
really actually seriously significantly
concerned with fighting neoliberalism
then you should know first and foremost
that Republicans are the worst examples
of neoliberals in America right now
today in fact neoliberalism was arguably
brought to the United States for the
first time by Ronald Reagan the great
democratic sheíll corporate neoliberal
shill Ronald Reagan sarcasm anyway so I
did an entire episode yesterday on
Republicans are neo liberals because I
you know if you don't understand that
then I have to ask the question and this
is to my progressive friends some who
are now my enemies which is totally fine
because you know I I can't really you
know there's a level of there's a level
of problematic politics that exists
everywhere and they exist in the
progressive circles as well but this is
a very key place where it exists because
if the entirety of your political
participation hinges on fighting neo
liberals and you don't even realize that
Republicans are neo liberals then what
the hell are you doing what do you know
a man
what do you what do you who are you
fighting what are you fighting for do
you even know what it is and this is not
to be insulting is not to be
condescending even though there is a bit
of condescension in my tone I will
gladly recognize that but come on so I
just let's let's let's get a definition
of it let's start there and I want to
start with the definition of neoliberal
from the Cambridge University Press
Dictionary and it's a very short
definition and this is what they say
quote supporting a large amount of
freedom for markets with little
government control or spending and low
taxes now to be fair that's a very
simple definition but it's accurate it's
not it's not wrong and some people have
the reason it's simple and it's
important it's because it creates the
framework that you should understand
neoliberalism through neoliberalism is
an economic paradigm neoliberalism are a
set of economic policies and decisions
that have created the entire framework
that we've been living under since
Ronald Reagan neoliberalism is economic
period now if you don't like that
definition I mean there's so many other
definitions you can go to Wikipedia it
says the same thing you can go to the
Oxford Dictionary economic dictionary I
couldn't find my book I was looking
forward this morning I knew I had it
somewhere but there's a definition of
neoliberal in the oxford economic
dictionary but if you don't like any of
those sources urbandictionary.com
actually has one hell of a definition to
help you understand and this is what
they said quote neoliberalism refers to
a political economic philosophy and
political economy is and it is one thing
it's not saying political and economic
its political economy neoliberalism
refers to a political economic
philosophy that has had major
implications for government policies
beginning in the 1970s and increasingly
prominent since 1980 that de-emphasizes
or rejects government intervention in
the economy focus instead on structured
free-market methods and fewer
restrictions on business operations and
that the most important class of rights
to expand are those of property
enforcement and
of opening nations to entry by
multinational corporations in a broader
sense it is used to describe the
movement towards using the market to
achieve a wide range of social ends
previously filled by the government
urbandictionary.com nails it you know
what else I learned on I mean I knew
this already from my studies but I went
to urban dictionary and learn what a
devil's triangle was because Brett
Cavanaugh said it was a drinking game
and something told me that that's just
not your so shout out to
urbandictionary.com neoliberalism is
economic paradigm but if you have
reduced neoliberalism to mean Democrats
that you don't like then you ask what
are you fighting what are you fighting
for because you know I got into politics
to fight the evangelical movement and
the the marriage that they have with the
Republican Party but also to fight
against neoliberalism because they are a
very specific set of policies that have
led to a place where Jeff Bezos can make
a trillion dollars a year and his the
the workers are on food stamps that's
that's a result of policies that put
emphasis on supply instead of workers
and demand neoliberalism is supply-side
economics trickle-down economics that is
neoliberalism is a cornerstone of
trickle-down economics and when you look
at the definition of it you can't you
can't help but realize Republicans are
neoliberals so to my progressive
comrades if you are 100 percent in this
to fight neoliberalism then how is it
that you can ignore the neoliberalism of
the Republican Party that's in power
right now implementing policies I get it
I get it you want to get rid of
neoliberal Zinn the Democratic Party
I'm with you Viva Viva Bernie Sanders
and his entire revolution that
revolution I was gonna say the
resistance but no vive la revolution you
know that the fact that we're getting
people like Acacio Cortes running for
office and Andrew Gilliam who's
demanding teachers make $50,000 a year
in Florida you know those people like
they if you want to call them Neal
liberals which some progressives have
started to do some progressives are
starting to tear down Alexandra Acacio
Cortez and and call her a democratic
corporate neoliberal she'll you know and
I'm like really do you even know what it
is because if you know what it was you
would understand why this new class of
progressives that are going to
Washington DC are going to be integral
in in changing the paradigm shifting us
away from the neoliberal paradigm just
for good measure before neoliberalism
was the the commonly accepted norm in
Washington DC was Keynesianism and
there's a great article from I can't
forgot what it stands for but it's F P
ifs org and it's from Keynesian ISM to
neoliberalism it's a great article and
this is what they said about
neoliberalism to help you even further
this was written in 2004 and so they
give you a date mark of 25 years ago
which would put you back in 1980 and
they say quote for the night last 25
years economic policy and the public's
thinking have been dominated by a
conservative economic philosophy known
as neoliberalism a conservative economic
philosophy known as neoliberalism the
reference to liberalism reflects an
intellectual lineage that connects with
19th century economic liberalism
associated with Manchester England
the Manchester system was predicated
upon laissez-faire economics and was
closely associated with free trade
contemporary neoliberalism in its
principally associated with the Chicago
School of Economics which emphasizes the
efficiency of market competition in the
role of individuals in determining
economic outcomes and distortions
associated with government intervention
and the regulation of markets
please tell me who fits this description
better than the right modern Republican
Party it was brought to us neoliberalism
was brought to us by Ronald Reagan and
if you look at the policies of Donald
Trump save his his tariffs that are
really not his economic policy as much
as his nationalistic pander
and fear-mongering he's using one
economic tool out of his entire
neoliberal economic toolkit one of them
he's sacrificing in order to carry out
his nationalism but besides his tariffs
everything else that he's doing is like
neoliberalism on steroids
it is excuse me it is neoliberalism
hopped up on cocaine like it is to the
extreme where they have now cut the
corporate tax rate down to 15% and the
responsibility that corporations and the
wealthiest have to society from which
they derive their wealth has been
reduced significantly which is a
hallmark of neoliberalism so if you as a
progressive are here to fight
neoliberalism why are you not fighting
it in the Republican Party as they
implement policies and why have you
reduced it down to nothing more than
meaning Democrats that you don't like is
it that you just want to fight Democrats
I mean if that's what you want to do
then that's fine but don't fight it in a
way that you ignore the culprits it's
like you know it's being a useful idiot
and I don't mean that to insult them I
think David said this that day to say
this on the show yesterday it's like
when you when you were actually
benefiting the very people that are
hurting your agenda that's not too smart
that's not intelligent whatsoever it's
like either I hate neoliberalism
therefore I'm going to hate help
Republicans who are even worse
neoliberals stay in power by complaining
about the Democrats who's neoliberalism
sucks and we need to get rid of it but
if you compare to what Donald Trump is
doing it is it pales in comparison
I hate neoliberalism so much and I that
I'm gonna help those Republicans get in
power and I'm gonna see it as a victory
because I stopped democratic neoliberals
from getting the power I'm sorry
but if that's not one of the best
definitions of the dumb dumb left thanks
for hanging out with me today folks the
bonus show is coming up thanks to David
for having me it's always a pleasure and
I will see you next time